[Música]
moscú no sólo querría controlar el
donbass eeuu sostiene que pretende
asegurar todas las zonas ucranianas que
conectan hasta moldavia mientras que los
rusos atacan de esa en un intento por
generar la entrada de alimentos y de
armas al menos una persona murió en los
bombardeos tenemos reporte desde ucrania
francia conmemora el día nacional del
recuerdo de la trata de esclavos la
esclavitud y su abolición el presidente
galo emanuel presidió la ceremonia en el
jardín de luxemburgo de parís mientras
la historia se cuenta de manera
diferente en lugares como martinica o la
ciudad francesa de nyon
y asesinar en colombia a marcelo beijing
un fiscal paraguayo especializado en
casos de narcotráfico lavado de dinero y
financiamiento del terrorismo
funcionarios de colombia paraguay y eeuu
iniciaron una investigación poco
buenas noches bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 mi nombre es marinera calle
y es un placer saludarlos empezamos con
la actualidad de la guerra rusa en
ucrania el presidente vladimir putin se
estaría preparando para un conflicto
prolongado en el que quiere controlar
territorio más allá de la región
separatista del donbass así lo advirtió
la directora de inteligencia nacional de
eeuu harry james ante el senado de ese
país sus informes sostienen que los dos
siguientes meses serán cruciales pues
afirma que putin podría incluso ordenar
una ley marcial en rusia y que aún tiene
la intención de ganar territorio a lo
largo de la costa del mar negro hasta
llegar a moldavia una de esas zonas
clave es la ciudad portuaria de odessa
que hoy fue bombardeada con tres misiles
hipersónicos en un hecho que dejó al
menos una víctima mortal ucrania afirma
que moscú quiere cortar el puerto de
entrada de armas occidentales y la
salida de granos de exportación
y precisamente en la ciudad de lis y
zhang ubicada en el óblast de lugansk en
en el donbass está rodeada por los rusos
la urbe está cada vez más aislada
mientras que los bombardeos continúan
hasta allí fue nuestra enviada especial
catalina gómez ángel y esto fue lo que
vio un parón en los enfrentamientos en
la carretera que traía análisis sean nos
permitió entrar hasta esta población que
si bien sigue en control de las fuerzas
ucranianas pues está en constante
disputa la ciudad está prácticamente
sola nos hemos encontrado con algunos
ciudadanos que dicen que el respiro en
la batalla les ha permitido salir y
hacer la compra a hacer lo que tienen
que hacer incluso nos hemos encontrado
con personas que están se acerca a la
estación de bomberos esperando que venga
ayuda humanitaria para llevarlos y
sacarlos de la ciudad de ésta no ha
llegado hoy el acceso hasta la ciudad es
muy complicado casi imposible y pues lo
que nos hemos encontrado es no solamente
destrucción muchísimos edificios
destruidos
se ve que hay bombardeos y también hay
artillería sino que también nos hemos
encontrado pues que la ciudad cada vez
está más aislada y cada vez corre más
peligro de caer en control de las
fuerzas rusas que están cada vez más
cerca
al menos tres mil 381 civiles han muerto
por la guerra en ucrania según las
estimaciones de la misión de monitoreo
de derechos humanos de la onu pero el
mismo organismo asegura que podrían ser
más los fallecidos en estas 11 semanas
de conflicto por otra parte de más de 8
millones de personas se desplazaron
internamente y los refugiados ya son
casi 6 millones marina sardenya tiene
los detalles
el drama humanitario se enzarzaban
ucrania en la semana 11 de hostilidades
y ataques indiscriminados del ejército
ruso naciones unidas dice que las
víctimas civiles superan por miles a las
más de siete mil reportadas por el
propio organismo entre heridos y
fallecidos en total hasta la fecha hemos
corroborado 7 mil 61 víctimas civiles
con tres mil 381 muertos y tres mil 680
heridos en todo el país desde el inicio
del ataque armado de la federación rusa
las cifras reales son mayores y estamos
trabajando para corroborar cada uno de
los incidentes
las cifras representan un agujero negro
especialmente en ciudades como mariupol
dado que los incesantes bombardeos del
kremlin impiden la entrada de los
organismos internacionales para
esclarecer las violaciones de derechos
humanos cometidas durante más de dos
meses de asedio son las autoridades
locales al menos 100 civiles continúan
atrapados en el último reducto de
resistencia ucraniana la acería de hace
hostal y miles más en las inmediaciones
de la arrasada urbe
debemos de entender que en mariupol hay
más de 100 mil civiles que están
esperando que se les dé la oportunidad
de salir y que tengan no sólo el deseo
sino también la oportunidad de salvar
sus vidas por lo tanto instó a todos a
unirse y a no rendirse en esta situación
tan difícil
hospitales escuelas o teatros que son
refugio han sido atacados la
organización mundial de la salud
denunció la muerte de al menos tres mil
personas por falta de acceso a sus
tratamientos médicos almost to handle
con casi 200 ataques sanitarios
verificados y documentados por la oms s
sobre el terreno ucrania es testigo del
mayor y más rápido asalto al sistema
sanitario a su personal y a sus
pacientes and space la emergencia
humanitaria se traduce también en el
número de desplazados internos más de 8
millones de ucranianos huyeron de sus
hogares para proteger sus vidas el 63%
son mujeres y 6 millones han salido del
país más de 8 millones de personas han
sido desplazadas internamente en ucrania
necesitan desesperadamente dinero en
efectivo medicinas y refugio por su
parte moscú continúa negando ataques a
la población civil y califica su
invasión como una operación militar
especial
ucrania que quiere suspender un punto de
flujo de gas por el que transita casi un
tercio del combustible que llega desde
rusia al resto de europa
el administrador de la red de
transmisión de gas ucraniano alega
visitó el comunicado un motivo de fuerza
mayor para frenar el suministro que pasa
por el punto fronterizo de su crãtica en
la región de lugansk y que está bajo el
control de los rusos desde hace casi dos
meses la compañía quiere transferir
temporalmente la capacidad al punto de
schütz a que es más al occidente y es
controlado por los ucranianos
supuestamente para garantizar así que el
gas llegue a europa sin embargo la
empresa gasística rusa gazprom alga que
es técnicamente imposible pasar esta
cantidad de volumen al último lugar
y cambiamos de noticia hoy 10 de mayo se
conmemora en francia el día nacional del
recuerdo del tráfico de personas
esclavizadas la esclavitud y su
abolición el presidente de manuel mayón
presidió la ceremonia en el jardín de
luxemburgo de parís y aunque la historia
está oficialmente incorporada en los
planes de estudios nacionales franceses
desde 2001 no siempre se enseña de la
misma manera la historia la tienen
nuestros colegas de france télévision
a la derecha el instituto jackman de
rivia pilot en la isla territorial
francesa de martinica a la izquierda en
institutos anti exúpery en la comunidad
en yoga en la francia continental dos
aulas y dos enfoques distintos de la
educación sobre la esclavitud es los
esclavizados venían de áfrica entre 300
y 400 eran encadenados en el casco del
barco donde hacía calor show un pedazo
de historia oscuro y esencial que debe
ser enseñado y discutido con las
próximas generaciones para no olvidar
nunca lo que sufrieron los hombres y
mujeres esclavizados en francia cuando
hacemos nuestra vida cotidiana olvidamos
que la esclavitud existió aquí en
martinica los alumnos repasan antes de
un examen poniendo a prueba sus
conocimientos de las condiciones en que
los esclavizados fueron llevados a las
antillas desde áfrica
los esclavizados serán traídos en la
carga del barco no tenían mucho espacio
spas no les alimentaban mucho y eran
tratados como bestias como animales al
otro lado del atlántico los alumnos de
3º del instituto sanger supreme y en el
continente francés discuten el tema de
la esclavitud a través de lo que han
aprendido de la radio las obras de
teatro y los poemas un día la historia
los recordara puede ser a través de
libros ilustrados con justicia y respeto
después de tanto dolor escribe es la
esclavitud es un periodo que nunca
debemos olvidar porque todavía existe y
se existe es la historia es la memoria y
también es lo que construye nuestra
sociedad si es una mente abierta nos
impide cerrarnos de ir hacia los
extremos yo les digo a mis alumnos que
debemos estar abiertos de intentar
comprender el pasado para ver el
presente de otra manera uno pesó la
esclavitud colonial y el tráfico de
esclavizados pasaron a formar parte de
los planes de estudios nacionales y se
integraron en los libros de texto cuando
se adoptó la ley atómica el 10 de mayo
de 2001
en españa el gobierno apartó de su cargo
a la directora del centro nacional de
inteligencia paz esteban la medida o vez
obedece al caso de vigilancia ilegal a
la que fueron sometidos decenas de
líderes catalanes vinculados al
movimiento independentista el presidente
pedro sánchez y la ministra de defensa
también fueron víctimas de las escuchas
a través de pegasus el programa de
origen israelí la nueva responsable del
servicio secreto es esperanza casteleiro
hasta ahora la número 2 del ministerio
de defensa de ellos y por primera vez en
casi 60 años la reina isabel segunda no
asistió a la apertura del parlamento
británico esto por problemas de
movilidad es la tercera vez en todo su
reinado que no lidera la tradicional
ceremonia las otras ocasiones fueron en
1959 y
1963 ambas veces estuvo embarazada en su
reemplazo su hijo del príncipe carlos y
hoy la agenda legislativa del gobierno
en el palacio de westminster y mató
mantuvo el tono formal para evitar tomar
postura frente a las políticas
en noticias latinoamericanas el fiscal
paraguayo marcelo pecci reconocido por
su trabajo en la lucha contra el crimen
organizado en su país fue asesinado en
la isla colombiana de barú cerca a
cartagena esto mientras estaba
celebrando su luna de miel con su esposa
claudia aguilera esta periodista le
contó a medios colombianos que estaban
en una playa privada cuando dos hombres
llegaron en motos acuáticas y le
dispararon la fiscalía y la policía
colombiana iniciaron una investigación a
la que se sumaron funcionarios
paraguayos y estadounidenses melissa
chávez nos amplía
el fiscal marcelo pecci fue asesinado en
la isla colombiana de barú cercana a la
turística ciudad de cartagena de indias
estaba encargado de investigar casos de
narcotráfico lavado de dinero y crimen
organizado en su país seguirá en la
lucha contra el crimen organizado una
lástima esto es muy doloroso muy duro he
conversado con el presidente iván duque
por teléfono
se ha comprometido conmigo para darnos
todo nuestro apoyo para resolver el caso
para buscar a los responsables
también he conversado con el gobierno
americano con respecto a esos quienes
también a través de colombia van a
apoyar casos como el del futbolista
brasileño ronaldinho quien en 2020
intentó entrar en paraguay con un
pasaporte falso el del asesinato de la
hija de un gobernador regional le dieron
reconocimiento a nivel nacional e
internacional al fiscal de 45 años que
además investigaba el asesinato de dos
personas durante un festival paraguayo
mientras tocaba a un grupo musical
colombiano conocido como el binomio de
oro ya tenemos informaciones que están
siendo recolectadas en los actos
urgentes y que son de carácter reservado
que nos ayudarán a identificar a los
responsables de este lamentable hecho
una delegación de la policía paraguaya
formará parte del equipo de
investigación en colombia en el que
también participarán funcionarios de
eeuu
el expresidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández se declaró no culpable de
narcotráfico ante un tribunal federal de
manhattan negó haber recibido millones
de dólares a cambio de no arrestar a
narcotraficantes mientras gobernaba
honduras entre 2014 y 2022 los fiscales
estadounidenses lo acusan de usar el
dinero para enriquecerse y financiar sus
dos campañas presidenciales
los abogados de hernández por su parte
denuncian que no lo tratan como un ex
mandatario
bueno hay no nos están tratando como un
expresidente de honduras lo están
tratando con un prisionero de guerra
actualmente te lo digo lo han aislado
completamente está en una unidad
segregada no tienes derecho del
privilegio de comisariato él no está
pidiendo más pero no debe recibir menos
de los otros reclusos es un ser humano
una buena persona no es terrorista no es
violento no sé por qué hasta nos han
insultado y algunas veces no han podido
este darme acceso o han negado acceso a
nuestro abogado la primera tienda física
de meta la compañía matriz de facebook
abrió sus puertas y está localizada en
san francisco california allí se exhiben
productos de hardware para experiencias
de realidad virtual y aumentada los
mercados de estas tecnologías tienen
previsiones de crecimiento exponencial
en los próximos años pero por ahora son
una apuesta costosa
cuando estén
no hubo una gran multitud esperando la
apertura de la primera tienda física de
meta pero los congregados asistieron con
entusiasmo
si este edificio será el primero del
estilo del apple store es histórico y
somos los primeros clientes estoy muy
emocionado y orgulloso
la tienda está en burlingame california
cerca de los laboratorios de meta que
desarrollan los hardware de realidad
virtual y aumentada en exposición sus
últimos productos como cascos inmersivos
y gafas de realidad virtual
en nuestra tienda puedes experimentar
quest un portal y ravens
meta quiere analizar las reacciones de
los clientes en relación a sus
expectativas
yo quiero jugar a juegos de disparos
quiero ir a visitar lugares donde no he
estado antes
me gusta mucho portal porque hacemos
llamadas familiares de su tenemos
familia en todo el mundo así que es un
buen producto a tener 11 tenéis para
exhalar meta y sus competidores han
invertido fortunas en tecnologías de
realidad virtual con la esperanza de
diversificar el modelo de negocio basado
en ingresos por en web y aplicaciones
como facebook instagram o whatsapp para
meta en el último trimestre los ingresos
alrededor de la publicidad supusieron el
97 por ciento del total se calcula que
la realidad virtual y aumentada será un
mercado de 500 mil millones de dólares
anuales en los próximos años y meta está
dispuesta a perder hasta 10 mil millones
de dólares este año en sus laboratorios
de realidad para desarrollar el futuro y
así nos despedimos sigan con nosotros
[Música]